zurück bei bild live mit den wendlers
den fällt gerade nicht mehr so ganz viel
ein die setzen jetzt auf nackt seit
november sind michael wendler und
ehefrau laura auf dieser erotik
plattform oni fans unterwegs das simple
prinzip falls sie es nicht kennen
sollten von only fans da zeigen stars
nackte haut und kriegen als sie als
gegengeschäft sozusagen ordentlich kohle
jetzt zieht laura dort so richtig blank
und verspricht mit mehr trinkgeld
prophoto noch mehr content also noch
mehr davon darüber sprechen wir hier im
studio mit unserer bild live show mit
janina cristallo janina ich war lange
romantisiert von morgen werden sie das
warum denn in erster linie geht es
natürlich bei only fans um geld um kohle
anfangs haben sie sich dann noch sehr
zurückgehalten also da sah man so
adventstürchen die geöffnet wurden autos
traf angetastet und wenig haut ja und
jetzt legt laura richtig los und das ist
auch ein konzept das aufzugehen scheint
man muss 35 dollar im monat bezahlen um
die bilder sehen zu können 20 hält davon
oli fans behält davon um die fans und
wie gesagt man kann auch trinkgeld
hinterlassen 600 dollar hat sich für
eines ihrer bilder schon bekommen und
dann wird es so gespielt dass man sagt
wenn ihr genug trinkgeld hinterlasst
dann bekommt ihr mehr fotos von mir also
ganz ganz klares ja ich würde sagen
nackt masche sozusagen um geld zu
verdienen was hältst du denn davon also
auch mal haben sie jetzt das prinzip
dieser dieser app dieser seite irgendwie
kapiert also es geht nicht darum die
handtasche zu zeigen die handtasche zu
öffnen es geht darum die bluse oder das
hemd zu öffnen okay da machen wir ein
häkchen dran aber was bringt es den
bendler also
meistens wird irgendwie aufgehen die
nackt masche was bleibt ihnen denn
vieles anderes übrig also wendler hat
hier in deutschland so viel verbrannte
erde hinterlassen mit seinen ganzen
corona verschwörungstheorien dass ihn
keiner mehr haben will und laura ist
davon auch betroffen und jetzt mir tut
laura einfach wahnsinnig leid und ich
finde michael wendler sollte sich
schämen denn die frau ist 21 jahre alt
die hat kein richtiger ausbildung kein
studium er hat dafür gesorgt dass ihre
karriere mehr oder weniger auch im eimer
ist und wie können sie jetzt geld
verdienen indem sie ihren po und ihre
brüste zeigt ich finde das ganz traurig
und wenn ich mich in die lage ihre
eltern versetzte dann würde ich glaube
ich nach amerika fliegen und versuchen
herrn wendler den kopf persönlich
abzureißen wir können immer noch darüber
sprechen dass sie ja selbst bestimmt ist
und auch mit selber entscheiden kann
aber wenn man dann nicht mehr so eine
große wahl hat dann ist es mit der
selbstbestimmtheit auch irgendwie
irgendwie dahin also ich finde das
ziemlich traurig dass ein 21-jähriges in
meinen augen dann irgendwie noch mädchen
junge frau so etwas tut und nicht fragt
mich was händler sagen würde wenn seine
tochter adeline das machen würde ob er
das auch zulassen würde ich bezweifle
dass ich finde ja hauptsache wir sehen
den nicht nackt das
werden wir ja gar nicht ahnen dass er
noch moralischen alle banken bilden
gesch für 1 janina kirche